[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the economics editor at
The Spectator Kate Andrews and guardian
columnist Zoe Williams
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the mail leads with the
government's plans to crack down on
channel Crossings reporting that people
arriving in small boats could be
deported and face a lifetime ban on
entering the UK
that story also features on the front
page of the times
that the guardian warns Rishi sunax
proposed laws on small boats could be
unworkable
the eye reports the Prime Minister and
Chancellor expected to rule out cutting
corporation tax putting them on a
collision course with Tory backbenches
Matt Hancock rejected advice to cut the
14-day covert quarantine period because
it would imply they'd been getting it
wrong that's according to the telegraph
the Metro leads on the historic
agreement to protect the world's oceans
which has been signed at the UN by
nearly 200 countries after 10 years of
talks
beijing's five percent expansion Target
signals end to the era of rip roaring
growth raise the front of the financial
times
and the big threes is the daily Stars
headline as the UK faces plummeting
temperatures and three snowstorms in a
week
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Kate
Andrews and Zoe Williams welcome to both
of you let's start with the front page
of the Daily Mail boat migrants to get
life ban this is um part of Rishi sunxa
top five priorities to stop illegal
migration through the channel to the UK
this is perhaps uh something that people
might not have known was on the cards
Kate
yes so when was she seen back in January
laid out his five priorities one of them
was to stop the small boats coming
across the channel a lot of people have
been asking how exactly you're going to
go about doing that and this week we are
now expecting the government to present
it's a new Asylum legislation which
looks like it's going to take a very
hard line on those who are choosing to
come to the UK via small boats uh both
the male and the times are reporting
that the new legislation will be a
Crackdown on anybody who chooses to come
in that way and could lead to an
indefinite refusal to allow them
re-entry to the UK so the idea is that
if you come via a small boat you will be
deported as quickly as The Government
Can Deport you possibly to a third
country like linking it up to the Rwanda
scheme and it is possible that you will
never be allowed to re-enter the UK
again or go on a formal path to
citizenship uh no doubt there's going to
be a lot of pushback to this policy
questions around its legality questions
around how this will affect Asylum
Seekers who genuinely feel fear for
their lives in the country that they're
coming from and the guardian has more on
that but the male and the time seem to
think that the legislation which is
expected on Tuesday uh will be a a very
hard Crackdown on uh asylums Seekers
coming to the UK which there the
government sources are describing as a
legal entry again that will be disputed
because
um in theory there is no other way for
many of these Asylum Seekers to come to
the UK apart from to enter how other
people would consider it to be illegal
but then you apply and you go through
the process to find out what your status
is and the idea behind this legislation
is that you will not be applying from
the UK and so that that is the point
isn't it how do Asylum Seekers legally
seek Asylum
well quite I mean the the flaws in the
plan are multiple
first firstly exactly as you say
there isn't a safe route to come into
the UK in many cases so if you have no
safe route and the unsafe route is
completely forbidden then you're sort of
writing yourself out of the convention
on refugees which is hugely problematic
and many many conservatives will dis
disagree with you know the Britain was
the Vanguard of developing this Humane
International
framework for after you know for the
protection of refugees after the second
world war and to grow back from that and
to to secede from it is absolutely huge
um but that's more of a moral case
legally this is for the birds really
because they say
you may be deported to a third country
the Rwanda plan has already been mixed
by the high court so it's it's actually
not legal with that within our own law
to deport you to a third part to a third
country
um let alone within European human
rights law
um and and furthermore
it's naked electioneering you know all
it does is try and put some as a Tory
Minister said to the guardian try and
put some clear blue water between the
conservative party and labor as they
kind of March into election planning now
that
everybody knows that party's plan for
elections and they create talking points
etc etc but to create this talking point
whose ramifications are so major both
not just in terms of the kind of
humanitarian and legal issues but also
in the Practical terms of if you're
going to arrest
all the people who come in on small
boats and await their deportation to who
knows where that's going to be an
enormous cost on on detention and you
know prison capacity and rights of the
child and rights of you know it's it's
practically an absolute brain
um and and so I think I think
realistically you just have to see it
for what it is which is a bit of
saber rattling with probably close to no
practical application yes Kate uh the
guardian Zoe's paper makes the point
that that
um Zoe was mentioning there that it's
unworkable and will only lead to tens of
thousands of people fleeing war and
persecution being locked up
that is certainly a possible outcome we
haven't seen the details of the
legislation yet the the guardian is
reporting that the home office and
number 10 are going to try to insert a
so-called break on human rights
legislation to address the issue that
Zoe just brought up about uh the fact
that the Rwanda plan has been rejected
by the courts the idea behind this new
legislation is that it would change the
law uh to make these kinds of
deportations uh possible through the
court and and to try to avoid uh some of
those uh Court stops you have the uh
former permanent Secretary of the home
office sir David normington being quoted
in the guardian casting doubt on the
feasibility of this plans and again
there are a lot of reasons to think it's
going to experience many hurdles the
conservative party seems quite insistent
that it wants to go down this route
there seems to be a feeling that even in
just a year perhaps even in recent
months that the issue of Asylum seeking
illegal immigration in small boat it has
become a bigger talking point amongst
the conservative Grassroots even in
areas that are in no way really affected
by this kind of immigration and so there
does seem to be more consensus and so
it's something that the conservative
party wants to push they clearly think
the politics of this
is going to work for them but whether or
not the policy the law and the hurdles
are something they can overcome is
another question and then to Zoe's point
you know aside from that almost separate
you have the moral arguments around this
and what happens to genuine Asylum
Seekers you know apart from Ukraine and
Hong Kong and a few select countries it
is basically not possible to apply as an
asylum Seeker to come to the UK you have
to show up on the shores Britain in some
capacity it certainly doesn't have to be
through a small boat but you have to
come here in order to apply and the idea
behind the small
boats is that if you came in that way
and we'll see the legislation if that
expands to other other means of coming
to the UK then perhaps you would
actually lose your right indefinitely to
applying to be in Britain it remains to
be seen the discussions around this bill
but Zoe what do you think back benches
will make of the lifetime ban on those
ever those people ever applying to to
stay in the UK
well I mean I I struggle to imagine the
policy meeting in which they said this
is going to be a plausible and you know
credible answer to the to the small body
problem because the the ideas that
people are tied up in its wheels for
years you know they wait so long for a
decision because it's in disarray so the
act the experience of this on the ground
whether you're operating under the old
system in which you can languish
indefinitely for a creaking border Force
to actually make a decision on you or
you are a band for Life by a government
who's who's kind of tenure is
probably quite short-lived and there's
no conceivable reality in which an
incoming labor government wouldn't
overturn this legislation
is it that isn't a deterrent you know if
you're even even the Asylum Seeker with
the best access to current government
thinking and information conceivable
would would not think oh this
legislation is going to put me off to go
into Britain because it both situations
are equally bad so what you're really
looking at and I'm and I you know I hate
to sound cynical of what you're really
looking at is a conservative party
simply trying to boost its popularity
ratings and make itself sound effective
by being unpleasant but there's not
going to be any practical application of
those measures let's turn to the I and
the budget uh another issue that um
they're predicting there will be clashes
with back benches over because the
chancellor and the Prime Minister
um uh set to rule out a cut to
corporation tax Kate
the next budget is a week on Wednesday
and the conservative growth Group which
is a relatively new group that is formed
out of uh former prime minister Liz
truss's most loyal supporters is really
pushing the government to u-turn on its
decision which be going ahead this April
to raise corporation tax up to 25 for
the biggest businesses
um and I suggesting that there's going
to be a bust up because the chancellor
and the Prime Minister are not keen to
take on that U-turn
um I suspect you know they're always
they're very often rabids out of hats at
budgets but I suspect we will see that
corporation tax rise uh not least
because I think it's a policy that Rishi
seen that personally very much believes
in he is not convinced that there is a
Laffer Curve effect when it comes to
corporation tax he thinks it's really
about bringing in incentives for
businesses to invest it's not so much
about that headline tax rate and that's
something he's made very clear for years
now since he brought in this policy in
March 2021 and it's not obvious that the
government would be prepared to you turn
on this not least because Rishi neck is
thought to remain very close to the
treasury close to his Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt and uh certainly plays a role in um
in in setting some of these policies but
the audio is reporting that this is
going to be to the Deep frustration of
those trust supporters who were adamant
that corporation tax needed to stay at
19 perhaps even go lower eventually in
order to stimulate more economic growth
yes and so we read that uh Liz truss
will not try to undermine where she soon
act but it's likely to get behind any
policies that are developed by the
conservative growth Group which of
course is challenging the prime minister
well I mean she's it it's funny that
statement because she says she will not
try to undermine him but it is of course
Very undermining to even to even be as
involved in politics and
um you know strategy thinking as she is
she's the previous prime minister I mean
for sure it didn't last very long but
she she is the kind of outgoing prime
minister and she should make like John
Major and be very very quiet for a very
very long time
um so it's about you've got to see it as
part of a slew of um moves she's made
you know she sort of kind of weighed in
on the subject of China she she's
weighing in now on tax
she's trying to stay relevant and
kind of mover and Shaker and
conservative circles against the
expectation that she will be very quiet
for a while
um now whether or not that's I mean I
don't I don't actually think it's
self-interested I think it kind of
represents the fact that it's a very
fractured party and all the old Norms
about
I was the way one behaves it in in kind
of the service of a new leader out of
the window and you can see that from
boris's Behavior as well so I think it's
I think it's a I think it's a party with
a lot of into Nissan wrangles and Liz
trusses interventions are more revealing
of the wrangles than they are about real
tax policy because you know who cares
what Liz just thinks about Corporation I
remember you previously um calling her a
chaos monkey
um
hahaha we'll let we'll leave it there on
Liz trust shall we um just very quickly
Kate let's talk about this story in the
Metro
um and it's suggesting that child care a
shortage of child care is costing the
country 27 billion pounds a year
yes this is a report from the center for
Progressive policy they suggest that 1.5
million mothers will be working more
hours if they had suitable Child Care
um I'm always a little bit skeptical of
numbers like that because it isn't
obvious to me that if they had a certain
option they wouldn't necessarily take it
that's true for men and women
um and and you know I I'm always a
little bit hesitant we put such specific
numbers on things but a very important
point that I think they are making is
that if you did want to go back to work
and work more hours
um that would be a very difficult thing
to do because child cares we have some
of the highest child care costs in the
oecd here in the UK a lot of that comes
down to regulation and red tape a lot of
that comes down to supply it's an issue
that you know a lot of prime ministers
have kicked that can down the road and
we certainly need to tackle child care
costs to allow women and men to make the
right decisions for them whether that be
to go back to work full-time part-time
whatever it may be they should have the
suitable option of more decent Child
Care policy indeed okay and Zoe for the
moment thank you we are going to take a
break coming up more of the press
preview including this on the front of
the Metro on the historic un oceans
agreement their headline The Tide is
turning
[Music]
thank you
you are watching The Press preview still
with me the economics editor and The
Spectator Kate Andrews and guardian
Economist Zoe Williams I come to you
first of all Zoe um let's have a look at
the Metro and uh tell us about the
biggest conservation win ever
this has taken quite a while to get to
this point
it's such an extraordinary story because
you know you know you can see how big a
deal is because un resolutions U.N
agreements take a really easy
it's very hard to get them onto the
front page of papers very hard to get
them into bulletins because they're
often like sustainable development goals
you know they're very big words but not
very much practical application and the
reason this has made such a splash if
you'll excuse the
um
it is quite concrete you know previous
at the moment 1.2 of oceans are
protected under international law this
would protect 30
of the of of the of the world's Oceanic
space from all kinds of things whether
it's kind of deep sea digging deep sea
mining fishing shipping
huge amount of oceanic life is protected
under these moves and I'd really love to
read the behind the scenes on who got it
away because it's going to have a
significant impact on you know trade
markets
profit
um all kinds of things in the service of
the environment okay this is hugely
significant isn't it after 10 years of
talks
yes it's it's it's taken well over a
decade to get this over the line and it
looks like December was a crucial Point
um at that time the UN biodiversity
conference was taking place and they
agreed to protect a third of c and land
by 2030 and it was clear that wasn't
going to be possible without actually
getting this kind of high seas treaty
over the line and and one of the really
difficult things around it is that so
much of this water exists outside of
national boundaries
um so negotiating that was very
technical and require countries to
perhaps take on more responsibility than
they otherwise felt that they had to do
in the past so um yes certainly a big
moment a really big agreement to be
struck
let us have a look at the um well
elsewhere in the Metro
Harry and Megan
is that in the Metro
it is in the Metro yes there's the the
story
um the king's emailing the sussexes over
the coronation because the big question
was will they or won't they attend Zoe
it really I tell you what it does I'm
sorry to sound kind of wonky about
newspapers but it really does go to show
which newspapers are favored by the
palace because the male has much more
detail on this story even though the
Metro seems to have had it first so
basically
um King Charles has emailed Harry to say
that he can that to ask whether he's
going to the coronation and Harry and
Megan have yet to reply but in the mail
there's the detail that they can retain
use of Frogmore Cottage
um you know remember this the withdrawal
of this was a huge Scandal earlier last
week
um that they were having this kind of
the place they stay when they come out
from America taken away from them that's
hanging in the balance now if they come
to the coronation apparently then they
get to keep the cottage which
incidentally is is when we call it
aquatic it's like rich people call
things when in fact they're castles it's
quite a significant it's quite a
substantial house
um so obviously the the unknown is still
unknown will they or will they not come
to the coronation but the the devil is
in the detail it if it looks a little
bit like they're sort of being bribed to
come which is quite surprising given the
rift that has that is kind of occurred
since the publication of spare but it
has always been reported that the the
King has been reaching out and and does
want them to attend but Kate do you
think they will and do you care
hahaha two very different questions I
don't I don't know if they'll attend I
think this is actually a really big test
for Harry and Megan and I think a lot of
the public have already decided how they
feel about this couple
um but so far they have they have
purposely tried to walk the line with
being extremely critical of Harry's
family while still insisting that they
want nothing but the best for the family
and they support the institution of the
royal family coming or not coming will
really show what side of the line they
fall down on there
um and if they come I think it becomes
slightly increasingly difficult for
Harry to do the kinds of interviews that
we saw over the weekend because clearly
if he comes ultimately this is still
something he feels worthy and that he
wants to be a part of okay we must leave
it there thank you both